mesmo que a sua voz estremeça falha a
partir da sua verdade mesmo que sua mão
trema
olha a partir da sua verdade mesmo que
seu coração acelere fale a partir da sua
verdade mesmo que de medo
fale a partir da sua verdade
bom essa história aconteceu em 2005
quando uma oportunidade incrível de
curso de gestão partes apareceu na minha
cidade de belo horizonte
o primeiro dia de aula e aquela boa e
velha rodada de apresentações
quem é você o que você faz quais são
seus projetos enfim seja devem conhecer
o roteiro tudo muito bom tudo muito bem
e chega a minha vez nariguda que sou eu
fiz questão de não esconder nada das
coisas que eu fazia eu acho que eu já
não queria deixar parte de mim pra trás
e aí eu falei
oi gente prazer eu sou aquela capaz ou
atriz
sou bailarina sou jornalista sou
produtora cultural também sou também
escritora professora de dança emendei
também sou empreendedora a engrossar o
caldo na verdade eu nem me senti
empreendedora de fato mas já estava
colocando em prática aquela história do
aparenta enquanto tenta provar pra mim
mesma que eu era assim uma colega lá do
outro lado da sala me solta em um sonoro
agudo menina que loucura você tem que
escolher ninguém consegue fazer tanta
coisa tão bem assim não
ninguém vai acreditar em você causa um
silêncio constrangedor ou eu porque não
tinha nem clareza nem confiança
necessária para argumentar bem um
sorrisinho de canto de lado e
desconcertante fez uma piadinha qualquer
só que ali nasceu um enorme pulga atrás
da orelha e porque não a pensava
por que eu não posso sim ser muita coisa
e trocar com as pessoas a partir de quem
eu sou
pois é
eu confesso eu confesso eu imagino que
muitos de vocês vão confessar junto
comigo não só na verdade essa curiosa de
uma figa que não se cansa em aprender
coisas novas que têm dificuldade de
focar lidar com a rotina que adora
experimentar jeito diferente de fazer as
coisas e que têm ideias a todo momento
uma camaleoa abelhuda e volúvel com o
espírito investigativo para todas as
coisas deste mundo meu currículo quando
eu ainda tinha um parecer um frankstein
experiências diversas em projetos
diversos com gente diversa e quando me
pedem para colocar na ficha do
consultório médico a minha profissão eu
demoro uns bons segundos porque sempre
fico com aquela sensação estranha de que
uma palavra só não é capaz de definir
bem o que eu faço
nem que eu sou e o mundo bom o mundo
muitas vezes jogou na minha cara que eu
sou mesmo inconstante talvez até
instável uma cabecinha confusa que
reluta em seguir o curso natural das
coisas
nasce cresce e escolhe morre gente como
eu tá mais pra nasce cresce experimenta
escolhe escolhe quem escolhe experimenta
experimenta experimenta
até que um dia morre mas para repara
presta atenção a gente olhar bem no
fundo vai fazer até bastante sentido
tipo se eu me sinto como um canivete
suíço
por que que eu tenho que me comportar
com uma tesoura sem ponta de sua costa
papel é tentar ser tesoura causa um
sofrimento danado gente assim como eu
que tem múltiplos interesses e milhões
de habilidades além de uma capacidade
enorme de adaptação
nós os múltiplos essenciais não temos
medo de sair aí desbravando esse mundo
aprender e reaprender em nossa defesa
caso vocês também sinto assim é porque
dói dói muito ter que abrir mão de uma
dessas possibilidades é como arrancar um
braço jogar um pouco de si no lixo
só que o mundo dos negócios e da
educação empreendedora e por que não da
educação formal falou pra gente livro
após livro que é preciso focar
eles vão dizer faça o favor de escolher
o mundo quer especialistas a palavra de
ordem meu caro amigo é virar tesoura e
aí você não consegue seguir com essa
idéia de viver dos seus talentos porque
você não consegue escolher qual talento
escolher só que se você não tivesse que
escolher esse mundo do empreendedorismo
criativo e de significado pudesse abrir
um portal mágico em que fosse possível
fazer duas coisas ou quem sabe 345 tudo
junto e misturado e se houvesse um jeito
de costurar tudo isso que você é
numa trama de retalhos bonita e que
entregar se o valor para o mundo que se
a sua multipotente realidade fosse na
verdade a sua principal vantagem
competitiva como se diz no mundo dos
negócios
eu sei ser multi potencial empreendedor
ao mesmo tempo dá trabalho porque mesmo
no mundo da multi potencialidade é
preciso certo foco para aprender porque
sem foco não a construção de nada mas
foco não significa ignorar um chamado
interno e simplesmente não fazer aquilo
que você sabe no fundo que tem que fazer
foco talvez seja encontrar o seu porque
organizando tudo isso que você é
entregando valor para o mundo e vivendo
disso tudo ao invés de escolher uma
profissão casar com ela e ficar até o
final que a morte os separe
a verdade é que eu venho ajudando muita
gente criativa e fazedor de coisas há
muito tempo e sempre quando tem uma
oportunidade como essa eu faço uma
pergunta aos presentes
quantos aqui se identificam com apenas
uma profissão médicos ou apenas médico
não quer fazer mais nada sou médico
médico médico blogueiro vídeo maker
fotógrafo
quantos de vocês aqui nesse auditório de
fato querem escolher uma profissão e
casar com ela
monogâmica mente até que a morte os
separe de idade uma pergunta quantos de
vocês
se sentem mais como tesoura do que como
o canivete suíço pode levantar ninguém
vai falar que não pode ser tesoura
ninguém pois é
na grande maioria das vezes a resposta é
essa
somos muito mais canivete suíço do que
tesoura
só que o mundo continua gritando seja
uma tesoura seja uma tesoura
a minha hipótese nada corroborado por
meios científicos é preciso dizer é que
somos multi potenciais por natureza que
a multi potencialidade é do humano assim
como a criatividade ou a curiosidade
a boa notícia felizmente aqui mundo
mudou e essa era a de encontrar
profissão em catálogo de rh o catálogo
da universidade profissões médicas
fechadas acabou felizmente acabou ea era
também de escolher uma profissão e casar
com ela até o final também acabou e
acabou também a era de empreender
só com terno e gravata planilha debaixo
do braço e plano de negócios de 200
páginas e acabou também esse jeito de
pensar que a gente tem que escolher uma
profissão e que ela vai pesar porque ela
é a única chance que a gente tem não é
ela não é a única chance a gente tem um
monte de outras possibilidades já dentro
da gente
do jeito que a gente é o mundo mudou e
ele precisa de pessoas muitos potenciais
como a gente pensa comigo
esse mundo está em constante
transformação constante transformação em
ebulição plena constante ele precisa de
gente habilitada a fazer um escândalo o
mundo a olhar as coisas por cima com uma
visão de drone esse mundo precisa de
gente habilitada a costurar as coisas a
encontrar os buracos que os
especialistas não enxergam porque eles
olham pra algum lugar
nós somos as pessoas capazes de tapar os
buracos e falta de especialistas
muito obrigada somos muito gratos aos
especialistas porque sim eles
construíram um uma quantidade gigante de
conhecimento vertical e aprofundado que
foi muito importante pra fazer a gente
chegar até aqui mas aqueles que se
sentem mais como o canivete do tesouro
eu digo que chegou a hora e mais do que
isso não somos apenas multi potenciais
mas somos também multi apaixonados
capazes de nos apaixonar
arrebatadoramente por assuntos diversos
e nos deixar impregnar por esses
assuntos ao longo da nossa trajetória
enquanto a gente vê essa é portanto a
minha trajetória e é o que eu aprendo
ensino há bastante tempo de como é
possível abrir mão de uma educação
empreendedora mecanicista
industrializada especialista para dar
lugar a um aprender diferente em que a
gente possa colocar os nossos talentos
em uso que seja mais simbiótica que seja
mais sinérgica mais orgânica e que
respeite de fato nós como seres humanos
e esse cara que tá querendo aprender a
empreender diferente ele é na verdade um
apreendê dor e ele sabe ou ele vai
descobrir durante essa trajetória que
primeiro autoconhecimento é a bússola
que guia esse caminho que conta pra ele
que ele é o que ele quer
segundo identidade é fonte inesgotável
de recursos já está aí dentro e pra onde
a gente pode voltar sempre que precisar
de novos recursos
criatividade é ferramenta de
experimentação que cria valor não só
para a gente mas também para o mundo
o cérebro mais coração são parceiros de
jornada para encontrar a simbiose entre
razão e emoção valor e estratégia
valores pessoais e estratégia cliente é
gente alguém com que a gente compartilha
o nosso melhor e que investe naquilo que
a gente tem de melhor também lucro o
resultado do valor entregue para o mundo
pra que a gente possa empreender com
significado enquanto melhora o nosso
entorno mão na massa é ferramenta
essencial de aprendizado pra fazer
enquanto aprende e para gerar clareza do
próximo passo
a rede é um espaço seguro de aprendizado
para trocar a competição pela
colaboração
sustentabilidade é meta pra te fazer o
que se quer pelo tempo que sentir
vontade e respeitando o planeta
metodologia por último é caminho na
fórmula porque esse aprendê dor tem que
caminhar
o próprio caminho ele tem que desvendar
a própria trajetória
bom mas por onde se começa jogando a
gente puxa o fio de dentro investigando
o próprio capital humano e criativo
abrindo e observando as próprias
ferramentas desse caso inverso isso tudo
que faz de você você e que é capaz de
gerar valor para você e para o mundo o
seu stock de competências e habilidades
talentos desafios histórias tudo tudo
que você acumula até aqui no meu caso
por exemplo eu sou bailarina desde muito
pequenininha me tornei atriz na
adolescência jornalista na faculdade
depois eu comecei a dar aulas me tornei
professora depois empreendedora depois
mentora depois a escritora e hoje eu
consigo dizer que eu tenho um trabalho
porque eu inventei
um trabalho que me permite usar todas
essas potencialidades
se eu fosse buscar uma vaga de emprego
possivelmente possivelmente eu não ia
encontrar uma que desce vazão a tudo que
eu tenho por que exatamente eu construí
o meu negócio em cima daquilo que eu sou
daquilo que eu tenho e daquilo que eu
acredito
isso tudo que eu tô contando pra vocês
se materializou através do meu próprio
negócio
a espaçonave que é uma escola de
empreendedorismo criativo que ajuda
outros empreendedores criativos a
transformar em tudo que tem em algo que
possa garantir que eles vão fazendo
aquilo que amam a espaçonave nasceu
quando eu consegui um projeto
patrocinado com dinheiro privado mas
financiado com dinheiro público pra ir
para londres fazendo mestrado nesse tema
eu ea sala de aula todo santo dia
sentava na frente da aula aproveitava
toda aquela experiência coletar
informação entrevistava a gente escrevia
coisa e compartilhava com uma rede de
pessoas que estava buscando a mesma
coisa que eu eu fui para londres pra
aprender a empreender mas acaba
ensinando também porque no final das
contas a gente ensina aquilo que precisa
aprender
o carro-chefe da espaçonave é o de
colaborar um programa online de dez
semanas que guia e ajuda empreendedores
criativos na construção dos seus
negócios e de um trabalho gostoso pra
chamar de seu
como amanda mall uma ilustradora de
minas de varginha que é apaixonada por
mulheres que é alucinada por plantas e
flores que decidiu ficar em varginha e
por isso usa a internet tá tudo lá tá
tudo lá
mergulhado o negócio dela ou também a
cissa guimarães
uma designer que também artesã que
durante um processo familiar descobriu
que o ato de escrever num caderno só o
ato de escrever um caderno trazia
tranqüilidade
autoconhecimento e confiança naquele
momento tão difícil
tá tudo lá mergulhado num negócio dela
ou elisa dantas de brasília que tem a
paixão pela costura e não só isso tem a
costura no sangue também porque a
cultura vem passando de geração para
geração e ela grita para o mundo que é
possível modificar o nosso entorno a
partir do ato criativo eu posso
modificar o mundo através do botão
pregado mas no botão que tem história
por exemplo o que todas essas mulheres
têm comuns negócios e carreiras com
português muito fortes e que bebem e que
dão vazão a toda sua potencialidade e
sua apaixonada unidade agora porque ser
um empreendedor criativo porque quando a
gente assumir esse espaço a gente pode
criar empreender tudo junto e misturado
a gente pode ver o todo e ser capaz de
conectar as partes a gente cria novas
sinapses no cérebro a gente é capaz de
equilibrar razão e emoção que a gente
também pode encontrar o que o mundo dos
negócios chama de diferencial já que a
gente de fato for fiel à nossa história
aquilo que a gente tem e que a gente é
dificilmente vai ter um outro negócio no
mundo que seja igual ao nosso contanto
que a gente de fato seja fiel a esse
capital humano e criativo
agora às vezes quando a gente começa a
querer voltar a usar toda essa
multipotentes realidade que a gente tem
às vezes parece que uma dessas
ferramentas desse canivete está meio
quem se ferrou já dá a gente não sabe o
que fazer com elas porque trabalho
trabalho e trabalho constante é um
processo de aprendizagem
não tem como eu não me modificar
aprendendo e modificar leva tempo e dá
trabalho
só que às vezes eu tenho a sensação que
esse processo de ser o universo isso é
quase como um peso porque é algo que a
gente possivelmente não consegue evitar
por mais que durante anos a gente se
fantasia de tesoura uma hora
as linhas do canivete começam a rasgar a
pele e querer sair para fora
então esse processo é um pouco da diva e
cruz
eu peço mesmo que doa mesmo que de
trabalho mesmo que incomode mesmo que
não seja fácil mesmo que de medo mesmo
que o mundo fale não seja um canivete
suíço
obrigada